let's talk about the electoral map that
Donald Trump recently sent out with just
over two weeks until Election Day
Republican presidential candidate Donald
Trump has released an electoral map that
is completely and utterly delusional
Trump emailed his supporters in the last
48 hours did one of these big
fundraising emails and he sent out an
electoral map which I will show you
shortly but before I do that here is the
quote that Trump campaign manager and
delusional in charge Kellyanne Conway
sent out the wording is hilarious in
this email and and just wait until you
see this map
Kellyanne Conway said Donald Trump must
reach 270 electoral votes to win the
presidency okay that's true at least
there's something that's accurate in
this email she goes on to say we've
outlined a map to show where we
currently stand as well as the possible
paths forward to win over the past month
polls have shown us winning Iowa Ohio
Maine Florida Nevada and North Carolina
if we maintain our leads in those six
states leads that don't exist as I'll
show you in a second we can reliably
claim 266 electoral votes and Hillary
can claim 193 so I read this and I said
okay over the past month polls have
shown us winning in like for example
Maine so I thought it must be
technically true right there must be
some poll over the last month that has
shown Donald Trump ahead in Maine but I
couldn't find a single one it and I
looked pretty hard this morning so lies
this is a lie but here's the part where
it's really rich and if you're listening
on the radio or to the podcast I
encourage you to check out this clip on
YouTube to look at the map that I'm
going to put up for you this is the map
that the fundraising email linked to
you'll notice a ton of red states you'll
notice very few blue states and you'll
notice a ton of gray states gray is code
on the Trump map in Trump's world the
world where he only sexually assaults
women that are attractive enough right
that's the world this guy is living in
all of these gray states that you're
looking at Maine Michigan Wisconsin
Pennsylvania Virginia all of these
states are too close to call according
to the Trump campaign so I said well
let's look at some
these right for example the map says
Pennsylvania is too close to call
polling average in Pennsylvania is
Hillary Clinton plus five historically
blue state Virginia on this map is gray
meaning too close to call this is
hilarious because Donald Trump has
conceded Virginia Trump has made the
call that they are so far behind in
Virginia that it's not worth investing
any more money in Virginia they've left
Virginia Trump has conceded Virginia and
Kellyanne Conway sends out an email
saying hey Virginia is too close to call
donate so we can fight for you and then
Colorado on what planet is Colorado too
close to call Clinton plus seven there
in an average of recent polls no
momentum for Trump no change in sight
Trump is lying to his supporters to get
them to donate imagine getting this
email Rachel and saying Oh Virginia I
want Trump to fight for me in Virginia
here's 50 bucks
Trump is left Virginia yeah this is very
very bizarre I mean he he could
technically still if he got nationally
he could win I think exactly but the
other issue I guess is that he doesn't
realize that to win he would need to get
all of the states that Romney had in
2012 and that's just not happening
that's right this map Pat doesn't even
have Trump already with Romney's 2012
states and Romney lost it this is just
totally delusional and you know what the
most hilarious aspect of this whole
story is that Donald Trump is the
Republican nominee that's part of it
yeah Kellyanne Conway's numbers don't
even add up if you take those red states
on the map and then add the six states
where they say is that Trump is polling
well yeah that only gets trumped at 263
and Hillary will be at 197 so even her
own math is off there even her lies are
wrong yeah but I feel like we all know
that math is not her best this if you're
a trump supporter do you justify this by
saying well it doesn't matter that it's
all lies and that the money you donate
and and say I'm from this state try to
win this stage will never go to trying
to win that state do you justify it by
saying hey the guy's got to raise money
somehow I mean
the trumpeters come up with some way of
justifying the lies no but what's more
terrifying to me despite all of his
ridiculous lies is that he still has any
support with what's happened recently
everything that has come out against his
assaults against women and everything in
that nature so I don't I don't
understand well what you're gonna have a
bad November 8th and raychel because win
or lose Trump is going to have millions
and millions and millions of people
voting for him on November 8th so I
would I would prepare yourself I know
you're not like a safe space type of
person but I would have something lined
up for November I'll try but what's
going to happen in Utah
well we so I'm guessing you checked out
what's going you tie is an interesting
state where Trump will probably win but
what was it Pat we talked Monday I think
where Evan McMullen the independent
Mormon candidate in Utah is within the
margin of error and if I mean the
Republican nominee not having Utah
guaranteed is a huge deal yeah it's a
four-way race it seems at this point
between a big McMullen Donald Trump
Hillary Clinton and Gary Johnson's even
polling well to their yeah but if you
were in Utah Rachel would you be voting
Trump no even in Utah you wouldn't go
nuts no no that's what I thought the
questions some have been emailing in
about is David could the polls be wrong
and this is brexit 2.0 that's a very
fair question that I don't have time for
today
but I'm going to address it tomorrow
specifically and clearly and
step-by-step the way I like to do let's
take a break I'm on Twitter if you have
any thoughts about this I am on Twitter
at D Pakman I've talked about how people
of all ages but particularly Millennials
are owning cars less and participating
more in the sharing economy and one of
the more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online from your smartphone over
the phone then you unlock it with your
zip card each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600
pounds per year for our audience Zipcar
is offering $25 a free driving credit if
you sign up at join zip car comm slash
david support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars
sign up at join zip car comm slash David